hello everyone and welcome to math
simplified i'm dr omar malik and welcome
to our new video series known as
superfood sundays
where every sunday we will discuss one
superfood that has immense health
benefits and also how you can
incorporate that food into your daily
diet
according to many dietitians a superfood
offers high levels of desirable
nutrients linked to promoting personal
health and wellness or preventing
disease and sickness
such desirable nutrients include
antioxidants anti-inflammatory agents
and other vitamin and trace element rich
foods
so let's begin and to start off the
series the superfood that we will
discuss this sunday is turmeric
turmeric scientifically known as curcuma
longa is a bright yellow spice used
throughout asia for centuries
grown for its root turmeric has an
ancient history of uses in cooking
fabric dyeing cosmetics and especially
as a traditional medicine in china and
india
its use in conditions such as rheumatism
severe pain fatigue and breathing
problems has been well documented for
over 4 000 years
scientists have identified a key
ingredient of turmeric that quite
literally gives turmeric its superfood
properties this key ingredient is known
as curcumin
curcumin is a pigment found in turmeric
that not only gives it its
characteristic bright yellow hue but
also has a range of health benefits
these include antibacterial
antimicrobial anti-inflammatory and
antioxidant effects
because of these wide ranging functions
turmeric has been studied in relation to
arthritis eye conditions cancer heart
diseases alzheimer's disease and much
more
so let's talk about some of these top
scientifically proven health benefits of
turmeric
number one curcumin is a natural
anti-inflammatory compound
inflammation is incredibly important for
our body it helps to fight bacteria and
viruses and also has a role in repairing
the damage done in your body by free
radicals it's a body's way of protecting
itself
although short-term inflammation is
beneficial it can be a concern if it
becomes long-term or chronic and attacks
your body's own tissues chronic low
level inflammation plays a key role in
the development of many diseases
including heart diseases cancer
metabolic syndrome alzheimer's disease
and various degenerative conditions
that's why anything that can help to
fight chronic inflammation is important
in the prevention and treatment of these
conditions
the curcumin in turmeric has proven
strong anti-inflammatory properties that
reduce the damage done by chronic
inflammation in the body
studies have shown positive effects of
curcumin on people suffering from
conditions such as rheumatoid arthritis
inflammatory bowel disease and many
others
this anti-inflammatory ability of
turmeric reduces the worsening of
pre-existing joint problems as well as
development of new ones in the people
with arthritis
in addition turmeric also has pain
relieving properties
the spice is reputed to relieve
arthritis pain as well
dietitians suggest taking turmeric
capsules of 400 to 600 milligrams up to
three times per day number two
turmeric is a powerful antioxidant
curcumin has potent antioxidant
properties
now to completely explain what oxidative
damage is what free radicals are and how
antioxidant work
we need a whole another video but to cut
it short just remember oxidative damage
is believed to be one of the main
mechanisms behind aging and the
development of many chronic diseases the
main reasons antioxidants are so
beneficial is that they protect your
body from this oxidative damage and the
development of many diseases like
cataracts glaucoma and macular
degeneration in the eyes
number three curcumin can boost brain
health
before scientists had a better
understanding of neurons it was believed
that they were not able to divide and
multiply after early childhood but
studies have shown this isn't true
neurons are capable of forming new
connections and in certain areas the
brain they can multiply and increase in
number also
one of the main drivers of this process
is brain derived neurotrophic factor
also known as bdnf
this protein is responsible for
promoting the life of neurons and also
plays a role in memory and learning
many common brain disorders have been
linked to the decreased levels of pdnf
protein including depression and
alzheimer's disease
interestingly animal studies have shown
that curcumin may increase the levels of
bdnf in the brain
by doing this it may be effective in the
delaying or even reversing many brain
diseases and age related decrease in
brain function
also there is growing evidence that
curcumin can cross the blood-brain
barrier and may help to protect against
alzheimer's disease
it works to reduce inflammation as well
as the buildup of protein plaques in the
brain that are characteristic of
alzheimer's disease sufferers still
since these studies were performed in
animals it's hard to say what the
results mean for humans and more studies
are needed to confirm this
number four curcumin may lower your risk
of heart diseases
heart disease is the number one cause of
death in the world
researchers have studied it for many
decades and learned a lot about why it
happens
unsurprisingly heart disease is
incredibly complicated and various
things contribute to it including
oxidative stress by free radicals
curcumin may help to reverse many steps
in the heart disease process
perhaps the main benefit of curcumin
when it comes to heart disease is
improving the function of endothelium
which is the inner lining of your blood
vessels
when endothelium gets affected it is
unable to regulate blood pressure blood
clotting and various other factors and
this dysfunction is a major driver of
heart diseases
several studies suggest that curcumin
can lead to improvement in the health of
endothelium
one study found that regular consumption
of turmeric is as effective as exercise
in post-menopausal females
in addition curcumin can help to reduce
inflammation and oxidative damage which
can play a key role in the development
of heart diseases
in one study of 121 people undergoing
coronary artery bypass surgery
researchers assigned them into two
groups
one group received a placebo and the
other group received 4 grams of curcumin
per day for a few days before and after
the surgery they found that the group
who took curcumin had a 65 decreased
risk of experiencing a heart attack in
the hospital
indicating that turmeric definitively
reduces their heart related issues
number five turmeric may help to prevent
cancer also
cancer is a disease characterized by
uncontrolled cell growth there are many
different forms of cancer that appear to
be affected by curcumin supplements
curcumin has been studied as a
beneficial herb in the cancer treatment
and has been found to affect cancer
growth and development
studies have shown that it has various
ways that it can control cancer such as
it contributes to the death of cancerous
cells it reduces angiogenesis which
means it prevents growth of new blood
vessels in the tumor
and it reduces metastasis also that is
the spread of cancer
whether high dose curcumin preferably
with an absorption enhancer can help to
treat cancer has yet to be studied
properly
however there is evidence that it may
prevent cancer from occurring in the
first place
especially cancers of the digestive
system like colorectal cancer this was
studied by researchers in a month-long
study in 44 men these men had lesions in
the colon that sometimes turned
cancerous the researchers found that 4
grams of curcumin per day reduces the
number of lesions by 40
so the bottom line is that turmeric and
especially its most active compound
curcumin have many scientifically proven
health benefits such as the potential to
improve heart health prevention against
alzheimer's and cancer
relieving joint pain in arthritis and
much more it's a potent
anti-inflammatory and antioxidant agent
while these benefits are possible they
are limited at this time because of the
curcumin scars bioavailability
the current scientific literature
regarding definitive benefit of turmeric
is still in its early development
so while scientists explore the benefits
of turmeric in their own way you can
introduce turmeric in one form or other
in your diet and start experiencing the
benefits yourself
you have the advice of billions of
people who have used turmeric for
innumerable purposes over the last four
thousand years well thank you for
watching this video don't forget to like
share and subscribe become a member of
our channel on youtube or support us via
patreon we at med simplified appreciate
your feedback and look forward to your
continued support as always take care
and i'll see you in the next video